good morning my name is Tim Brady I am a
partner here at YC a group partner which
means I work with the companies during
the batch closely I have started three
things prior one of which was Yahoo back
in 1994 so a lot of what I'm going to
talk about today stems from from that
experience so as Kevin said I want to
talk about a building culture how to
think about it at this stage of your
company and in why it's important now
culture can be pretty broadly defined so
let me be super clear on what I'm
talking about really to me culture is
just behavior in company culture kind of
is that implicit set of behaviors inside
of your company they should inform your
employees on how to behave
I guess when done right they should
inform the employees inside of your
company how to behave when it hasn't
been explicitly laid out for them and
the good news if you do it right if you
get a right the right culture the right
behaviors will support a good business
and hopefully a great business and over
the course of your company over the
history of your company it will support
that in a lot of kind of intangible ways
that are hard even to describe but
that's why it's important that's how you
should think about it at this stage
don't overcomplicate it right that's
really it
so you're probably asking yourselves
right at the beat at this stage of the
company like you have so many things on
your plate you're so busy it almost
seems like a luxury to be thinking about
culture right and that's kind of the the
you're not wrong to be asking that
question and the reason is is that when
your company gets going like these are
three phases that you'll be going
through as you build your company all of
you really are at this top stage that I
call the idea stage right talking to
customers iterating the product
experimenting iterating the product
hopefully you raise some money at some
point to allow you to continue to do
that and at some point in the future
you're going to reach product market fit
alright if you think back on the product
market fit talk that Michael gave a
couple weeks ago and when you do that
hopefully you'll raise a whole lot more
money and begin scaling the company now
scaling the company almost always
requires hiring a lot of people right
and the people that you have inside of
the company prior to hiring a lot of
people are really your cultural DNA
those are the people that are going to
be involved in hiring and training that
next wave of people so it's super
important that you get it right you get
that slide subtitle this kind of the
first 20 employees
that you get in and there's no magic to
the number 20 it's really that set of
employees that are in place when you
begin scaling the company because again
those folks are going to be highly
involved in hiring and training this
next wave so if you get it right if
those first set of employees are this
embody kind of the culture and the
values that you want inside your company
you have a much higher likelihood of
building a strong and coherent culture
the reverse is also true right if you
make mistakes if you get the wrong types
of people inside of the company early on
they're gonna be involved in hiring and
training and those mistakes are gonna
get propagated and it'll be much harder
later on to build to kind of correct
course and try to build a coherent
company right so that's why it's
important to be thinking about now I
know you have a lot on your plate in
starting this company but what you need
to do doesn't take a whole lot of time
for the most part it's just some
conversations with your co-founder and
so I came up with a list of six things
that you can do now to help you or to
help the likelihood of you building a
strong and coherent culture first one
be proud of the problem you're solving
kind of seems silly to say but you need
to write if you don't have the problem
yourself you need to identify with the
people that do have the problem and you
need to be really proud of the fact that
you're solving it for them right because
building as I'm sure you're gonna if
you've heard already and you'll continue
to hear buildings you know building a
company's heart it's a long process and
there will be some really difficult
times and if you're not proud of what
you're doing it's really hard to
maintain the level of energy and
enthusiasm you need to sustain the
company right sometimes where we see
founders go wrong is they choose an idea
with their ego they choose an idea
because it sounds good to tell their
friends at a party right and when times
get tough you know it's really hard to
maintain that level of energy and the
reader the reason energy and enthusiasm
is important not just for sustaining the
company but everyone around you will see
how you feel about the company rain to a
large degree that will set the tone for
your culture a couple of batches back we
had a YC alum come and tell his story he
he went through the YC program a few
years back he applied with four other
guys with the idea of helping retailers
liquidate their excess inventory that
was the idea they started with and they
did all the right things talked to
customers iterated experimented and he
raised some money and he got to to
search for product market fit and he
continued to to search for product
market fit ultimately they ended up kind
of had a good business for a little
while but they also ultimately ended up
in the business of makeup for teenage
girls right they didn't identify with
the problem and when times got tough
they just didn't want to be there right
they didn't identify with their
customers and he and he told the story
of where the employees around him
actually came up to him and said hey
like it doesn't look like you're
enjoying what you're doing
and ultimately they ended up shutting
down the company next when you do find
the right problem to solve one that
you're proud of create a long term
vision that others will follow it's much
easier to create a great culture if
people who identify with the problem
you're solving know you're solving it
they'll raise their hand and say hey I
want to be part of what you're doing
right we call it kind of it you can call
it a North Star for the company and say
it in a way that will inspire people it
should give purpose to the work you're
doing
it shouldn't describe the work but it
should talk about the purpose of that
work and let me give you a couple of
examples to illustrate what I mean
Tesla to accelerate the world's
transition to sustainable energy pretty
inspiring right no mention of an
electric vehicle you know if you said oh
we're building the world's best
electrical vehicle that's good you'll
inspire a handful of Engineers who-who
implicitly understand kind of the
technical challenges that come with that
but if you're gonna build a big company
you need to attract kind of a broad
array of people this does that another
example
Microsoft's original a computer on every
desk in every home it's kind of
laughable now but in the early 80s like
this was crazy talk
I hate computers were only for
businesses and hobbyists but this vision
you know laid out by Bill Gates and Paul
Gallen
attracted the right type of people to
their company right the hobbyists that
had the capability to help them build
the type of company knew they needed to
bill build saw this and and we're
excited about it it attracted and
allowed them to kind of build the type
of culture that they need it at
Microsoft
last one when you're all familiar with
organize the world's information and
make it universally accessible and
useful
again no mention of the product doesn't
say we're building a kick-ass search
engine all right so once you're able to
come up with kind of an inspiring vision
to attract the right people to your
company the next thing you should do is
have a conversation with your co-founder
about the types of values and behaviors
you want to cultivate inside of your
company right ultimately the purpose of
this at this stage in your company is to
use as a filter for the hiring process
right it should be a short list and at
this stage it's fine that it's informal
if you're lucky enough to move on and
grow like ultimately maybe this list
becomes a more polished corporate values
list this is probably the seed of that
but it's this stage it doesn't need to
be polished right you don't need to
publish a blog post on it it's just a
short list less than five things and
this will help you during the hiring
process to make sure that you're you're
letting the right type of people inside
the company right this is in addition to
that skill list that you'll need you
know job to job description the skills
that person needs this is you know above
and beyond that so let me take you
through a couple of examples and I
apologize these are actually more
corporate value lists they're a little
more polished yours won't need to be
this polished all right Spotify
innovative collaborative sincere
passionate and playful right
you can see pretty pretty clearly how
you can use that set of lists that this
list to begin screening potential
employees
Atlassian right this is a little
different the way they make the list
like it doesn't have to be just
adjectives like the Spotify one was open
company no [ __ ] build with heart and
balance don't [ __ ] with the customer
play as a team and be the change you
seek right
a little different you can see how this
came from a conversation between
co-founders right like I don't want to
work in an environment that's Riley
political no [ __ ] right that
translates into you know kind of a
hiring filter just like if someone seems
political in any way let's not let them
in the company him or her in the company
so come up with this list right again a
shortlist what type of company do you
want to build what type of behaviors
will support the business you're
building and then create that list but
don't let it just be a piece of paper
right don't put it in a drawer and wait
for the marketing department to polish
it a few years later you have to model
that behavior for better for worse the
early employees will look to you for the
cultural cues right you can't say you
know do as I say not as I do right you
have to walk the walk they will take
their cues from you for when thinking
about this list to the extent you can
make sure it's externally focused it's
much better to build a culture that's
focused on the customer than it is on
how you treat one another inside the
company look your shortlist can have
both but the more important ones are
creating a like having it externally
focused over the long haul that will
serve you much much better and let me
give you an example of of what I mean by
this so move fast and break things
you've heard this right Facebook this is
what I consider an internally focused
thing if you're a project manager or an
engineer at Facebook trying to decide
what to do next
this doesn't offer you a whole lot of
guidance right think back to kind of the
definition I gave of company culture
right it informs employees how to behave
when it hasn't been explicitly laid out
if you're deciding what next product to
build this doesn't help at all it just
tells you to move fast
right shouldn't be a surprise when you
look at this
that some of the privacy violations that
they've been charged with have occurred
at Facebook right I don't think for a
second anyone at Facebook set out to
violate anyone's privacy but their
culture shirt certainly didn't help them
didn't give them the guide rails on
where to stop right
contrast that with kind of Google's
early motto don't be evil
not particularly prescriptive
necessarily but it's outwardly focused
right it lets the employees and the
world now like hey we're we're force for
good and when you think about kind of
that policy that Google has with its
engineers they're allowed to work 20% of
their time on these independent projects
it's pretty pretty impressive that you
haven't heard of any of those go astray
right pretty amazing given given the
data they're sitting on again outwardly
focused right it gives some guide rails
to the employees and on how to behave
next have a conversation about diversity
and I'm not just talking about ethnic
and gender diversity here I'm talking
about a diversity of opinions can you
create a culture where people with
diametrically opposed opinions
strongly-held can coexist can you foster
conversations that are loud but then
people walk away and are okay how
important is that to your business right
there's plenty of research out there
that suggests that companies that are
able to foster this type of environment
have a diverse environment that isn't
always agreeable tend to be more
creative they tend to be better problem
solvers and the reason I put this up
there is it's it's really hard because
most of the advice when you get going
when you're hiring the first set of
employees is to hey check tap your
rolodex talk to friends talk to former
colleagues right those people you know
whether or not they're good engineers
you know whether or not they embody the
values that you're trying to put into
your company they're known quantity
and at that stage it's a good thing but
they're also probably a lot like you
right and you can find pretty quickly
that you've built a pretty homogeneous
environment in trying to hire too
quickly so have this conversation how
important is it to you to your company
to have diversity because if you think
you're gonna wake up at a hundred
employees and then start a diversity
program you're fooling yourself it's way
too hard it's too late by then so have
that conversation it's tough I don't
have the right answers on what that
looks like but have it it's important so
once you've done all that had those
conversations put a hiring plan in place
right don't just let it happen
from the very first employee make sure
you're following a process there's ton
of stuff online about hiring process ins
beyond the scope of this talk but
consider all those conversations you had
with your co-founder the type of values
you're trying to instill in the company
and the type of diversity you want and
make sure that's part of the process
from day one right and make sure you
assess whether it's working
especially the early employees right
after you hire your first couple of
people make sure you get back together
with your co-founder a month or two
after and discuss whether it whether did
what it should have like did it filter
the right way do you have the right type
of people in your company at this point
and if it didn't it didn't work well
improve it plan on evolving it right
you want it tested by the time you get
to the point where you have to scale
fast right you want a process that you
know works by then so that's it all
right again not too early you have a ton
on your plate and you know again what I
would I've given you hopefully are just
a few simple things that aren't too
time-consuming just conversations you
can have kind of thought experiments
with your co-founder that can help kind
of build a solid foundation
for building a culture later on thanks
everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
you